قد يكون لدينا قريبًا سلاح جديد في الحرب ضد الطمع 19. صوتت لجنة استشارية من إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) للتوصية بترخيص الاستخدام الطارئ لحبوب جديدة تسمى molno piravir ، وتقول شركة Merck ، إن الحبة يمكن أن تقلل من الخطر النسبي للدخول إلى المستشفى أو الوفاة بنحو 30 النسبة المئوية للانضمام إلينا الآن هو الدكتور إليوت بار ، وهو نائب الرئيس الأول للشؤون الطبية والعلمية العالمية في ميرك أه سيدي ، شكرًا جزيلاً لوجودك معنا هنا اليوم ، هذه بالتأكيد صفقة كبيرة ، ولكن تم التوصية بها من 13 إلى 10. كان لديه بعض المستشارين الذين لديهم بعض التحفظات ، لذا فأنا أعلم أنه سيكون هناك بعض الأشخاص الذين لديهم مخاوف بشأن هذا الدواء ، فماذا تقول لهذا جيدًا أعتقد أنه من المهم حقًا أن يكون لديك العديد من الأدوات في مجموعة أدواتنا لمكافحة جائحة covet 19 نحن نرى أن هذا جائحة لا يمكن التنبؤ به للغاية ، ونحن على ثقة تامة من أن هذه ستكون إضافة مهمة حقًا ، حسنًا ، فهذه إضافة إلى صندوق الأدوات كما تضعها  من الواضح أن
الفعالية هنا هي 30 ،
لذا انظر ، هذا يعني أن هذا بالتأكيد
شيء صحيح ، لكني أتساءل عما إذا كنت
تبحث عن طرق لجعلها أعلى من
30 في المائة
جيدًا ، فهناك بعض الأشياء التي يجب مراعاتها
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، أظهر التحليل الأول
فعالية  50
وكان هذا هو التحليل الأساسي
الذي وقفنا عليه من أجل الدراسة
بالتأكيد أه
معلومة أخرى هي أن
معدل الوفيات يظل فائدة
عالية جدًا لذلك
فقط غالبية الأشخاص الذين ماتوا في هذه
الدراسة كانوا في مجموعة الدواء الوهمي
الغالبية العظمى لذلك أعتقد أنه من
المهم أن نتذكر أن هذا
دواء مهم للغاية
وسيكون مفيدًا جدًا للأشخاص
لمنع العلامات والأعراض
والمضاعفات الرهيبة التي يمكن أن تحدث
مع covid19 ، ثم على omicron
الذي من الواضح أنه بديل مختلف.
أنت تعرف مدى فعالية
مولنو بيرافير ضد أوميكرون
جيدًا يختلف أوميكرون عن
الفيروسات الأخرى بسبب بروتين سبايك
وهذا  ليس المكان الذي يعمل فيه هذا
الدواء على الإطلاق ، حيث يعمل الدواء في
جزء مختلف تمامًا من الفيروس
،
ولم يتغير التركيب الجيني لأوميكرون في
هذا المجال ، لذلك نتوقع أن الدواء
سيكون فعالًا تمامًا ضد omicron
ولكن العمل مستمر  سيخبرنا بالتأكيد ،
نعم لا ، هذا مثير للاهتمام حقًا ،
ثم عند انتقاله ، هل يساعد ذلك في
الحد من انتقال الفيروس أو إيقافه
جيدًا ، سننظر في أن
لدينا تجربة إكلينيكية تجري
الآن
وأشخاصًا  تم الكشف عن شخص لديه
رغبة ولكن ليس لديه رغبة كبيرة حتى الآن
ومعرفة ما إذا كان أخذ المضاعف
سيقلل من مخاطر اكتسابه مشفرًا ،
فهذا شيء
قيد الإعداد ونأمل أن يكون
له فائدة إضافية مهمة
للدواء
[  موسيقى]